I got choked up watching the trailer
after watching this movie man
[Music]
so Coco's the newest film by Pixar Pixar
always crushes it in the animated
Department for the most part this is a
newest adventure it follows a kid named
Miguel basically because of this kid's
great-great-great grandfather I believe
is he the great great or great great
grandfather goes back a little way their
family has banned music but he really
wants to be a musician but he's not
allowed to
long story short his adventure takes him
to the land of the dead where he meets
this trickster named Hector he needs to
meet his musical idol we're just start
with this one we'll start with the
animation first of all the animation is
great
it's like Pixar ups their game every
time the colors are vibrant the land pop
something as simple as the bridge to the
land of the day is one of the most
magical things you'll see you're like I
want to walk across that bridge
immediately
sorry Asgard your bridge sucks in
comparison also the music is very catchy
after my first watch I didn't find a
song that's going to stick in my mind
but generally speaking the music as a
whole was a great ensemble of music the
music was as warm as the tone and theme
of the movie which really is in the
words of the great Vin Diesel daily this
movie is all about family and the love
and flaws of a family every family has
flaws every family has absurdities that
you're like that doesn't need to be
there doesn't mean the family itself is
bad such flaws are paved with good
intentions but they should be addressed
and assessed that maybe you don't need
to do that it's just a good look at
family maybe your family has rules and
they're doing those rules they say
they're doing it for you but they're
really doing it for them or maybe you
have rules for your family and maybe you
say you're doing it for them but you're
really doing it for you what is the
quest was a really touching one and by
the end I was a sobbing weeping mask no
lies no BS cried in this movie I love
the characters to the main kid brought a
lot of heart I have no idea who voices
him look it up right now yes he's been
nothing I've seen but I imagine I will
see and hear more of him he was great
also loved Hector Hector's one of those
weasels you meet you're like you're kind
of a con artist aren't you but as the
movie goes on it expands on him and you
really see where he's coming from movies
not so black and white it's not like
well he's just one of those scoundrels
how the movie really expands on him he
has layers I'm telling him the funny
thing is for it taking play
in the land of the dead it's the world
that feels the most alive never in my
wildest imagination have ever thought of
an afterlife being this interesting I'll
take this over to hanging out in a cloud
city forever
it really does celebrate the fact or the
concept that after life you're no longer
bound and a world like that's really
limited by your imagination and whoever
built this world has a huge imagination
and I for one am really glad that I got
brought along on this adventure and also
brought in on some culture that I didn't
know much about I'm not down with my
Mexican death lore so I knew nothing
about it other than the fact that I
believe it's the celebration that's
happening at the beginning of Spectre
for me that's a fantastic thing it's
Thanksgiving weekend you need something
to do with your family after you're all
stuff you go into your food comas and
you wake up what to do let's go to the
movies close watch cocoa because cocoa
is definitely worth watching and
definitely worth buying on blu-ray all
right guys so cocoa have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]